Une mère en larmes qui seprésenb
dans la ville d'Uvalde au Texas.
Des parents affolés qui
établissement de près de 600
élèves devenus le théâtre d'une
autre fusillade.
vers 11h30 du matin une série de
masse à cibler l'école qui
accueille des élèves du
deuxième, troisièmeatatatatrième
niveau primaire.
le suspect de ces crimes haineux
a agi seul poursuit le chef de
police de la ville.
la majorité des victimes sont
des enfants. Le tireur présumé a
été neutralisé lors de
l'intervention policière.
Le tireur âgé de 18 ans était un
résident de la ville. Un
résident américain qui serait
présenté à     à bord d'un
véhicule armé d'une arme de
poing et d'un fusil.
Parmi les victimes, la grand-
mère du tireur présumé. Une
tragédielllllève encore le
débat autour des armes à feu.
"Qu'est-ce qu'on fait?" Demande
de sénateur démocrate du
Connecticut qui rappelle la
tuerie de Sandy Hook, la plus
violente des 10 dernières
années. Il y a plus de scierie
de masse que deux jours dans une
année. Nos enfants vivent chaque
jour dans la peur à chaque fois
quntntntntntnt en classe. Le
sénateur du Texas Ted Cruz crie
à la politisation de la
tragédie.
"Les démocrates et les médias
tentent de politiser le drame et
de restreindre les droits
constitutionnels de citoyens
respectueux." Dit-il.
Les motifs de ce crime
demeurent inconnue pour le
moment. Mais le pays est sous le
choc.
"Trop c'est trop. En tant que
nation, nous devons avoir le
courage d'agir pour nous assurer
qu'une telle chose ne se
reproduise p
"Combien d'enfants, combien
d'écoliers sont témoins de drame
et voit leurs camarades mourir?
Sommes-nous dans un champ de
bataille?"
Joe Biden a isisisisisisise en
berne des drapeaux à la Maison-
Blanche, ainsi que sur les
bâtiments et lieux publics des
États-Unis jusqu'à samedi soir.